how bad you think market crash is going
to be these people real estate and
mortgage people they and you can tell
them by the way just let them know can
you handle the truth from his point of
view are you guys tough enough to handle
the truth yes or no some of you guys are
not clapping tell me you guys are like
no I'm not really tell me some good
things how bad how ugly can it get
the worst case which I hope I'm wrong be
civil war inside America
that's more than a crash that's a Civil
War and my prediction is that Donald
Trump will have good friends his sons
and I are good friends
I went to his son's wedding here at
Mar-A-Lago
and uh
he's a leader
if they try and put him in jail
I hope they don't
we'll have a civil war
because this last election was stolen
I had lunch last Saturday
thank you
I had I had lunch last Saturday with the
secretary of state from West Virginia
and he says America is watching Arizona
and they want to figure out how we
handle it because they know
he says it's not fraudulent it was
criminal what they did
with the ballots
but again it was a man named Stalin who
said it's not who votes that counts
it's he who she who counts the votes
and ladies and gentlemen
we'll lose the right at The Ballot Box
we lose our democracy
and that's why there's raid on
Mar-A-Lago violated the Fourth Amendment
we cannot let this country come apart by
these criminals running our government
we need new leaders immediately
so the worst it could it could get is
Civil War I think the best we can
express is probably a depression
where are we going into it as I said
last night you know what we do we we
print money to solve our problems
and all that does is increase debt and
craze more freeloaders social welfare
I'm not against social welfare but don't
print money to pay for them
at the same time our debt escalates our
debt to GDP right now is 120 percent at
90 percent debt the GDP were bankrupt
that means every dollar we spend we go
deeper in debt right now
so our debt is now in the trillions I
don't know how many trillions have
really I've heard that's two 260
trillion I don't know how they measured
anymore
at the same time they raise interest
rates into a recession
this has never been done before
so that's why I'm saying that somebody
intentionally doing something to bring
America down in the world down
and there's a video of trump speaking to
I think the United Nations or something
and he's telling the German contingency
back in 2018
he says don't trust the Russians don't
depend upon the Russians
and now Russia can cut off their power
so there's something really goofy going
I'm not privileged to find out about it
I just I want to
put some fear into you
because the more dangerous the mission
the better you've got to be
I talked about last night how
you know when I was prepared I was at
Camp Pendleton preparing to go to
Vietnam was at Marine helicopter Gunship
pilot our life expectancy was 30 days
30 days
now most people said that's not good I
said well it inspired me to become a
better pilot
[Music]